hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast regulation of precision
medicine it is presented by Neal a
Belson
JD lawyer Potomac Law Group Washington
DC mr. Belson handles transactional and
regulatory compliance matters and
focuses on legal matters relating to
precision medicine life sciences
information technology and health IT I
am Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring in this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box it appears on the
screen will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming mr.
Belson I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you today regular
session medicine and just a few words
about how I got into precision medicine
as you will see this is a field that
both from the legal perspective and as
well as the scientific is continually
evolving in effects a very wide range
industries it effects
remarkably diverse area of legal aspects
as well and I just can't couldn't think
of anything that would be a more
interesting to do for the rest of my
career then to be a part of the
evolution of the legal and regulatory
framework of one of the most I met areas
and one of most exciting areas of law
medicine and science so I'm going to
speak about a number of recent
developments in the regulation of
precision medicine there are so many we
ready our recent developments in the
area of precision medicine that does in
all honesty someone could probably pick
about as many areas as I'm not going to
cover as the ones I do and make a good
case for those and not the ones I will
cover shame and disgust nonetheless I
hope this will give you a good overview
of some of what's taking place in the
legal and regulatory field guarding
precision medicine
now a few background notes I'm going to
briefly discuss the FDA regulatory
scheme because most of my talk will
focus on FDA first understand that FDA
does not regulate the practice of
medicine FDA requires drug and device
manufacturers to demonstrate that their
products are safe and effective for
particular uses and only allows them to
include on the their labels the uses
which specifically have been approved by
FDA however it doesn't regulate those of
you who are physicians in your practice
and it does not preclude your using
medicines for off-label purposes in fact
as you'll hear off-label use sometimes
contributes to a sort of a development
dump of evidence that supports precision
medicine one important issue that will
come up and push
medicine another background issue is the
issue of informed consent a lot of
precision medicine revolves around the
use of genetic or health data of
individuals one of their patients are
just volunteers who contribute their
information and within the area of
informed consent there are two types of
information really two types of concerns
that need to be considered the first is
FEMA which you are probably familiar
with as physicians and to disclose
protected health and information
requires HIPPA informed consent and
should be noted with HIPAA that if the
information is D identified so that it's
not traceable back to the subject this
is not really just removing the name it
means removing a lot of additional
information that could be such as
address and phone number and many other
types of information that can make the
injury the information back to its
source but if it has none of that
identifying information that's not
subject to HIPAA regulation also
informed consent as a research subject
is also subject regulation and the
subject needs of a research study for
example doing genomic research on a
patient's data to develop new devices or
drugs that requires a separate consent
from the patient which describes the
kinds of uses leads which the NATO may
be used and it also requires the patient
to we had a bill advised for the subject
to be advised who must receive the
information and what are the possible
purchases and oftentimes of practice
both consents what we can see included
on the same form okay now to the
precision medicine basically a who's who
of the federal
seas that are involved I'm going to
speak mostly about the Food and Drug
Administration's role they have almost
certainly been the prime mover on the
regulatory side of precision medicine
I'm doing a particularly focus on the
product development side of precision
medicine and in that regard FDA
regulates the C and a safety and
effectiveness of drugs and medical
devices they're the ones who must
approve the commercial marketing of
drugs and devices and and they can take
enforcement action if the products of
filmmaking that safety and effectiveness
standard
another important agency which I'll
briefly touch on is the Center for
Medicare and Medicaid Services there's
CMS because they're the ones that handle
Medicare coverage and basically their
approval for coverage of a precision
medicine of a product is very important
in it and it's commercial law in this
commercial value so they also regulate
to our wrinkling test laboratories for
all purposes accessories on humans and
for all purposes except research to
other agencies that I would briefly
touch on NIH or the National Institutes
of Health is mostly focused on research
and development rather than on the
regulation of precision medicine and
they have what's known as the Ovilus
program where they're seeking to obtain
a million individuals across the country
who have agreed to make available their
health data and genetic records for
research purposes
similarly the Veterans Administration
has what they call the million veterans
programs doing with a similar of getting
a million veterans to contribute their
data so that they can do research
on medical conditions of relevance to
veterans a brief rundown of the general
regulatory system for drugging devices
FDA is for drugs they're the ones that
grant a that approved drugs for
commercial marketing and also to speak
briefly about the drug regulation the
standard that they must give that they
use to determine whether a drug to be
marketed or a new use of a drug approved
that's what they call safe and effective
and drug development it's not cheap and
it is not sure toughs
a tough Center recently at the
University of top Tufts University
recently calculated the cost of
developing and getting approved a new
drug as 2.6 billion dollars for one drug
that's including many failures and it
can cost it can take ten plus years and
I've listed the two segment centers
within FDA that that are involved with
drug evaluation and approve Oh brief
synopsis of the drug development process
the first first you start with basically
drug discovery and optimization that's
where a company identifies potential
drug candidates once it gets that
actively to tries to optimize that lead
I'm making tweaking the initial compound
and make it more potent and less risk of
adverse of that Vence then they have to
do preclinical studies which are
normally done on animals which although
I should mention and I'm not going to
touch on this briefly FDA is looking to
develop alternate and very exciting
development DEA's looking to reduce its
use of animal studies and use more in
vitro and simulate the test
and we still know the presentation on
that very exciting development but for
now preclinical testing usually involves
animal studies if those continue to be
promising both in terms of the
effectiveness and the low toxicity of
the compound they can submit an
investigational new drug application to
FDA and FDA does not object and place a
call on the investigation they can go
ahead and start clinical or human
testing phase one is a fairly small and
short test where they take healthy
patients and just test the drug for
safety Phase two they do effectiveness
as well it's larger they do
effectiveness studies they do dose e
studies and of course continue to
monitor safety and then phase three of
the largest usually involving a large
number of sites now what's noteworthy
about the traditional clinical trial
process is only about 12% of the
cantering candidates that start queuing
trials ever achieve actual commercial
approval from FDA so this is not only an
expensive process it's a very
inefficient one I've briefly talk about
some accelerated approval programs that
FDA and expedited approval programs and
if they operates that well not directly
limited to the precision medicine often
effects precision medicine drug
candidates because so many of them are
directed at products that would that
address unmet and high urgency needs
I'll talk about the accelerated approval
program allows FDA to approve a drug if
it demonstrates in effect on a surrogate
endpoint rather than on for example the
final disease of the patients response
to the final disease but a surrogate
endpoint considered likely to predict
the clinical love outcome it could be
approved under that accelerated approval
program and it's
they're very relevant to a to percision
medicine because that surrogate endpoint
often as a biomarker it's available as
noted on the slide for drugs which can
treat a serious condition and provide a
meaningful accept advantage over what's
currently available not meaning it will
advantage could be any of several things
it could be more effective it could be
less adverse effects or it could treat a
second of the population which is not
effectively treated under existing
therapies for example oftentimes they're
nothing but trouble only effectively
treat a portion of the people suffering
from a particular disease and if your
drug treats a different segment on
what's treated by current therapies that
would also the basis for qualifying for
the accelerated improvement program and
your product can get approved faster
than otherwise would almost certainly
have to do post-marketing testing to
verify that yes that surrogate endpoint
was in fact a valid endpoint and yes the
drug is effective against the endpoint
condition there are several other
expedited approval programs that I'm
just going to briefly show the slides
and not discussed just so you have a
sense of what else is out there there's
a fast-track program and again you can
you know get my presentation and you can
cease with them we'll get more details
on some of the other expedited approval
programs there's no need to discuss all
of them here there's the breakthrough
therapy a priority review and some of
those programs allow expedited review by
FDA once you submit a new drug
application they may involve and they
may provide allow FDA to assist you in
drug development they're generally
targeted toward unmet needs or see
improve drugs candidates which are peer
superior to existing products and
address serious conditions now I'll
briefly go over the FDA's medical device
regulatory scheme also very relevant to
precision medicine and there's they have
three classes medical devices us one it
is the lowest risk products class to
which is quite relevant to precision
medicine as you'll see as a moderate
risk product that generally requires a
premarket notification known as a 510 K
which which in which you demonstrate
that your device is substantial and
what's substantially equivalent to
currently market and or what FDA cons a
predicate approved device in class three
are drugs that they're present a greater
risk where there's insufficient evidence
to show that the drug is safe and
effective and not that cost could be
very important for a precision medicine
because if there isn't a predicate or
pre-existing device of a particular
category normally you would
automatically be submitted to this more
rigorous class three classification
however FDA also has a tool that allows
FDA to classified low to moderate risk
devices as a class 1 or class 2 even if
there is no analogous pre-existing
device as you will see that turns out to
be very important for from the
standpoint of some very important
criticism medicine device products and
development brief overview of the
history of precision magnet medicine
regulation in the federal law in 2015
President Obama and the State
the Union address announced what called
the precision medicine initiative within
the NIH that ultimately has led to
what's now that all of us program I
refer to within FDA it led to FDA is
establishing a community platform
because precision precision FDA
currently in beta where they are looking
to basically develop a collaborative
community for conducting of
bioinformatics research and development
and also looking for new approaches
within regulatory science another major
law impetus for federal involvement a
precision medicine was the 21st century
America's Kiera's Act passed by Congress
and enacted toward the end of 2016 which
funded precision medicine research and
quite a lot of significant stuff for
this presentation is a C it required FDA
to develop a program for put real world
evidence it also excluded certain
software functions including those that
found that some that have a medical
support function from regulation as
devices and also address another number
of issues that while not directly and
exclusively a part of precision medicine
are quite important to its development
such as it emphases attempts to increase
healthcare interoperability and prevent
or limit information blocking the
breakthrough created a breakthrough a
device track and various other things
that I've listed here now I will talk
briefly about FDA guidance documents
very important for how FDA was regulated
precision medicine if FDA waits to for
Congress
to enact legislation that will take a
long time will be generally very
nonspecific and regulations
similarly the path to it promulgate a
new formal regulation is slow and quite
likely because of the rapid development
of precision medicine adopting formal
regulations by the time they are
formally
promulgated weak FDA could find that its
approaches are obsolete or inaccurate
because everything is so rapidly
evolving instead they've developed
they've relied heavily on what they call
guidance documents we'll talk about
several those are non-binding documents
that represent what Afghan cause its
current thinking on a particular topic
and which should be viewed as
recommendations they usually issue a
draft guidance documenting and public
comment and then they issue a final
guidance some time after when it could
be a little over a year they've shared a
cup some that are a couple of years old
and then final guidance is still not
available on both the drafts and the
final guidances are available on FDA's
Wade website now of all the topics are
going to discuss the one I would spend
the most time on here is real-world
evidence
real-world evidence is such an important
part of precision medicine that there
are a number of conferences that are
that specifically are limited and focus
on real-world evidence and the
significance of real-world evidence is
that it is a prospective alternative in
many instances to randomized clinical
trials those inefficient goes in
efficient product development paths that
take over two billion dollars and
usually fail
and as noted the 21st century cures
active required FDA to developer
regulatory program for real-world
evidence in fact a lot of the attend a
lot of the activity is taking place more
on the device side to this point and in
addition to their cost and low success
rate there are a number of deficiencies
with the traditional clinical trials for
example they may not simulate the actual
product use clinical trials often
involve patients that are between 18 and
65 years old but it may be that the
actual population likely to use a drug
is older than 65 or if the disease is
rare you may not be able to get enough
of patient sample to Dominico minimum
meaningful clinical study and you may
not be able to do a meaningful you may
not be able to include patients who have
comorbidities in a traditional clinical
study because they have multiple because
the existence of many diseases creates
too many variables so we it would be
ideal to develop replacements and that
is the basis of an important FDA Yaya's
document on real-world evidence by FDA's
decisiveness the high standard that was
issued last year and you will see when I
discuss these guidance documents and
other regulatory initiatives how many of
them took place within the last twelve
months that is evidence how quickly this
field is evolving this one by the device
center and also the biologic Center
which has it regulates a small portion
of devices as well contributing this now
what exactly is real-world evidence well
first of all
real-world evidence is not the same as
anecdotal data or anecdotal experience
we are world evidence is clinically
valid evidence that is it's clinically
valid evidence that comes as a result of
an actual clinical study design FDA
distinguishes between what they call
real-world data that's the anecdotal
stuff and real-world evidence electronic
EHRs insurance claims data disease
registry data data that a patient may
obtain from cells monitoring devices if
they considers all of that to be
real-world data it's often generated not
with the regulatory purpose in mind for
example EHRs may be and put together
more with an eye toward making the
record of the patient's health and for
insurance claims purposes that's by
itself that is not real-world evidence
that's not useful necessarily for
regulatory submission real-world
evidence as FDA considers it is clinical
evidence obtained by using real-world
evidence real-world evidence as I'll
explain requires a careful of the study
design but done properly it can replace
those traditional clinical trials and
certainly instance is specifically
real-world evidence can be used instead
and this is basically developing a
real-world evidence can be used instead
of a randomized clinical trial or as a
supplement to reduce the size of a
traditional clinical trial to perhaps
add new uses on the device label new FDA
uses to generate
host marketing data that if they may
require ism
as a condition of granted accelerated
approval if you're doing a clinical
study it can be used to a traditional
clinical study you can use real-world
evidence to generate evident data from
your control group you can use it to
demonstrate the IO monitor that you're
using to measure whether or not your
drug worse I can use the oil evidence to
demonstrate the validity that Iowa
marker and there's a meaningful and
accurate reflection of the disease and I
should also know that safety and
effective advocacy is safe and effective
standard that is he required for
clinical studies and drug approval also
applies to any study by of real-world
evidence and here we thought about how
you generate a whirl of real-world
evidence study you can use data from a
from retrospective studies for example
it could consist you could go back and
look at claims data you could go back
and look at disease registries and you
could use prospective data you could say
we're going to for example for our
device we're going to prospectively use
set up a dis a registry to monitor all
use of the heart of the zeis device and
they were set and you will
systematically collect data from EHRs
from the registries perhaps from others
so from insurance claims and and it can
be prospective as well as it or it can
be both you can use both retrospective
and prospective data the key issue at
the point is is that you would approach
FDA and similar to a clinical study
excuse me you would
see a place similar to a traditional
clinical study you would say we'd like
to we have this hypothesis we believe
that this device of is effective for my
measuring this and will have this effect
and the only difference is that rather
than having a set up new clinical trials
you would collect your data from actual
patient use from those registries and
you wouldn't necessarily have to do or
you could do less of those randomized
clinical trials and in fact last year
FDA actually approved the new indication
of a device based entirely on real-world
evidence yes as you see there was a
transcatheter aortic valve replacement
and a new they preclude the new
procedure and the way they did is when
the product was originally approved the
manufacturer set up a registry and over
the course of a hundred thousand uses by
physicians hospitals etc there were six
hundred records of off-label valve and
vial of procedures and they demonstrated
the devices used for this violence these
600 off-label uses demonstrated the
safety and effectiveness of this val/val
procedure and as a result the company
was able to get approval for FDA for
this additional procedure with their
device without having to do any new
clinical trials all of us was developed
on patient records based that which were
generated after the price was approved
for its first use and this allowed how
much the FDA was actually I believe the
42nd national regulatory
Ziya among the various countries to
approve the initial use of the procedure
because they're then slow and procedures
around 2010 but because they used
real-world evidence they were the first
regulatory agency internationally to
approve this additional use and so with
the significance of real-world evidence
is that it can be a much less expensive
much more I hear it because it monitors
actual use of patience of a device or
ultimately a drug in real and real world
contexts with actual real-world patience
much faster path to get less expensive
much faster path to get regulatory
approval and what's more meaningful path
to getting it because if the data is
based on actual use on real patients so
the real-world evidence could basically
be a game-changer from a regulatory
perspective the development of new drugs
and new devices and FDA highline has
highlighted the need for real-world
evidence because right now there's not
really a system for aggravating the kind
of data that will systemic that would
support real-world evidence conclusions
not what there ought to be being charged
and other mega claims data use is
collected using many systems many not
designed for regulatory submissions and
opportunity and information is about not
being used as it could and opportunities
being lost and FDA hopes that by
expressing its willingness to accept
regulatory submissions for approvals
based partially or even entire than on
real-world evidence it can create
incentives for this kind of systematic
collection information and the mes
they list here is actually an initiative
at FDA to create a voluntary network of
partners to link it synthesize their
real-world data to improve the death the
universe of available information that
can support real-world evidence
applications regulatory submissions
basically create a broader universe of
data from which to draw conclusions and
actually have eleven proof concept
product projects in this program on
their website who talk about another
area in precision medicine that the FDA
is active in genetic variant databases
these variant database genetic variants
of it basically talking about music
mutations and these studying these
genetic variant databases can be a very
valuable resource and identify what are
the potentially significant genetic
variations this is done by comparing for
example the genomics of patients who are
healthy with those who have a particular
disease condition trying to identify if
there are specific genetic differences
that characterize those diseases and
that can be the basis for developing
drugs and devices that treat them but
very often the database about genetic
variations is contained is not available
to the public it's in proprietary
databases of R&D companies for example
farmers could be pharmaceutical
companies and if you look at FDA
recently issued a guidance document that
address I'm dressed on this very point
if you look at the data was issued april
2018 give you an idea of how a recent
power current so much of this activity
is and the goal is to encourage
the greater does just enough to Jeanette
variant data into public databases that
are available to the general public to
the researchers to product developers
and this dreck this diagnose that FDA
published basically it says that
publicly available databases that meet
the standards ran out in the second
bullet points could be used to support
the clinical validity of genetic variant
assertions and what that means is
basically if you're claiming that a
device for diagnostic product it's
useful for testing against a certain
condition and you're claiming this
genetic and this genomic variation this
genetic data is it for this bio water is
an indication of the particular
condition you can use evidence from a
publicly available database to say yes
in fact this condition or this genomic
pattern or this biomarker is in fact
linked to the disease that your device
is monitoring your testing and the
greater the information that is in the
public kinetically a variant database
the more tools that the product
developers will have the more data they
will have from which to identify
relationships between disease disease
and the certain biomarkers in your
genomic variations the more they'll be
the faster they will be able to they are
the more effectively hopefully they will
be able to develop tests this is quite
useful for a new generation sequencing
or NGS based testing in DES and others
now it's about another another recent
initiative and related to what I just
said
recent initiative by SJ relate
specifically to in test based tests and
the problem is FDA is a region already
to a framework for Diagnostics which was
developed for Diagnostics that only
measure a limited number analytical
analytes are analytical markers so they
publish their not they publish their new
guidance addressing that published the
same day as the one I just mentioned
just in April and this is specifically
record apologize if a new generation I
meant to say next generation sequencing
and this is again published just two
months two months ago and they Thea
stressing that it adopts a doctor they
are flexible and adapt their approach to
regulating NGS based tests and I
mentioned earlier that the significance
of that part of de novo process
basically a lot of if I can go back a
second they are specifically focused on
in aiding in the diagnosis of suspected
germline disease or these are genetic
diseases that were either inherited or
newly new genetic diseases that dumb
arose a notable and this in a in the in
a particular individual and in the most
case of that I don't believe in that
there are any currently marketed
Diagnostics that address that monitor
germline diseases which would mean
they're all because there's no critical
critical justing marketed device they're
all they know how they all have to go
through that pre-market approval process
it would normally be
however because of that a normal process
FD a-- is basically able to say that
that next generation sequencing
diagnostics which we that consensus
standards it's developer for measuring
such products are de novo and they
class two classification instead of
requiring a full pre-market approval
basically a analogous to a drug
application the set of studies they can
basically go through the pre mobile
market notification of the 510k
even though they're the first of their
kind if they do not appear if they
appear to present-- will moderate risk
another important area where FDA is
active and as you'll see also the CMS
which monitored that this along with
Medicare is the area of companion
diagnostics now companion diagnostics
are devices which provide specific
specific diagnostic information that are
essential for safe and effective use of
a specific drug basically it means that
the companion diagnostic device will
indicate for example couldn't get any of
several things but it could indicate if
the drug is appropriate for a particular
patient it could indicate whether or not
the drug is effective for that
particular patient but basically it
could indicate whether the particular
disease condition which the therapeutic
treats is exists or it might indicate
genetic information indicating that a
patient is there it's not suitable to be
treated for a particular therapeutic and
this case FDA has on the issue a draft
guidance as they solicit comment prior
to developing the phone the final one
and they actually actually have
companion diagnostics are not new of
other precision medicine as although
they are a very important part of
competitive precision medicine you can
see a list of existing companion
diagnostics right now
and FDA strongly that recommends here as
in other areas that you meet early with
the agency to devote to generate to if
you have a companion diagnostic that
before you initiate drug trials they
arrive strongly recommend that you have
a hidden fee Japan the diagnostic ready
to ready along with your drug candidate
so that in fact you can test the two and
develop the two together basically using
the device to to verify that the drug is
safety or ineffective now here I'm not
gonna tell I haven't talked a whole lot
about CMS but it's were noteworthy that
CMS the Medicare agency in FDA have a
parallel review program which allows
both agencies to current concurrently
review devices including companion
devices and in fact just recently
actually I should say that this parallel
review program has actually approved two
devices including an NGS based testing
device under this category helper review
program that allows both CMS and FDA to
review and simultaneously or
substantially simultaneously a primo a
product thereby assuring that not only
is a product approved but it's also
covered under Medicare as soon as it's
approved very important the question of
reimbursement and FDA or notice our CMS
just recently interested issued what
they call a national coverage
determination indicating that the
certain NGS tests for advanced cancer
which were FDA approved or cleared can
receive Medicare coverage if assumed
our conditions are met and the knowledge
that you could have that your
pre-approved product would also be
eligible for Medicare coverage create
such an important incentives for product
development and for physicians important
incentives for product use another area
that is likely to only become more
active at the FDA Donoho process was
recently used to approve the first time
a directions to consumer genetics test
which is used to evaluate use for
consumers ordinary customers to an I
weigh an individual's genetic
disposition to certain diseases and
medical conditions so this is an
overview of summon my new means all of
the regulatory topics but just a few
concluding thoughts first of all the
pre-existing regulatory scheme that
existed is often not was developed not
intended for precision medicine and FDA
and other agencies have often
demonstrated quite a bit of flexibility
creativity in making possible the rapid
advance of precision medicine if you're
involved in product development I would
strongly recommend you approach to your
agencies and especially FDA very well
all early and often in product
development they want to help you they
want to learn about your technology and
your products as their development so
they become educated and so they can
provide their input early on they don't
want to see if the first time in disobey
Product Approval and obviously another
key takeaway of what I said is the
regulation of precision medicine is
constantly evolving and quite likely
anything I've told you today will be
different would be different six months
from now so I think you very much for
listening feel free to contact
if you have any questions or would like
to discuss further any of the topics I
have discussed or any other topics I
haven't discussed relating to the
regulation of precision medicine I thank
you for your attention
Thank You mr. Belson for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for let's get started our first question
is could real-world evidence replace
clinical trials well I find particularly
exciting of all of the many topics I've
addressed real evidence would certainly
be up there at or near the very top
because it has enormous potential to
reduce the cost in time of developing
new drugs and products and devices to
reduce the cost to reduce the time to
make it possible to study rare diseases
and space of the gentleman were really
more usable information that clinical
trials because of more accurate
simulates accurate real-life conditions
having said that in some instances
real-world evidence could in the case I
mentioned has replaced clinical trials
it's probably best in its element when
you have a product on the market and
you're using real-world evidence to
support additional indications for that
product because it's being used on the
market that's being used by real-life
consenting consumers and you're
generating actual information
commercial of clinical use in that
regard it's strongly advisable to if you
want to get contantly additional
indications for your product when you're
speaking with FDA to get that initial
approval you might want to contemplate
setting up a product or disease registry
to measure that all uses of that product
in in a particular context now where its
pathway is less clear-cut right now
might be the initial approval of a say
for example a new drug because you
wouldn't necessarily have that that body
of patients being treated with the
product what you could generate that
real-world usage information so in such
cases you might be able to still use
real-world evidence as a control because
you can monitor the real-world use of
what currently is on the market and
measure that against your clinical your
traditional clinical data for the new
product the but I still have hopes that
it could be used universally but the
pathway to replace a traditional
clinical trials for say a new drug
candidate that's a new chemical entity
is much less clear-cut
thank you for that looks like we have
time for one more question how would all
of this information help me as a
physician okay in a lot of different
ways for example the differently
real-world evidence and this is the
whole purpose of a precision medicine is
intended to assist clinical
practitioners in making more informed
decisions the genetic sequencing test
and the products that utilize it might
be able for example to
to identify you might see symptoms of
disease you might not know the causes
and in fact or finding out he is a lot
of seemingly similar diseases actually
have quite different genomic or other
underlying causes and that's probably
the reason why most pros only work
against a certain portion of the disease
population the the development of
genomics based test genomics based
analysis of patients information Jen
could it give you more information as to
what is the underlying cause and instead
of her likes it was on a first line the
second lighted medication given to all
patients for a particular system you
might be able to make a much more
informed judgment about the underlying
genomic or other compa you would all by
real world evidence of information
discussed here idea of evidence as to
what has worked for enough for other
patients in similar situations so how
much weight of database of information
available to you for other piece of
usage if the genomic data being
developed through use of the variant
databases would create more linkages
between different symptoms different
biomarkers that you could use to
determine what is the what you're seeing
and whether what is a particular disease
back bearing biomarkers are you know
genomics with a particular disease or
set of symptoms and also measuring
whether or not a particular drug that
your diet or other treatment is actually
impacting that indicator biomarker so
it's going to make you get helping it
make more informed decisions
it will about what the patients are
suffering about whether a drug is
working about what has worked with other
patients and be able to help you
diagnose which of any number of causes
why patient is there isn't responding
which of any number of potential causes
actually is the cause of your patients
symptoms so and also the new regulatory
pathways being develop such as those for
real-world evidence could result in
faster and more useful products than
what you have now so I think I'm
starting to mean to interrupt you please
that's fine there's a faster and more
precisely targeted products than the
remedies you have now additionally I
would also point out there are companies
that provide services where they can not
do database analysis of a particular
patient and they are claiming that this
has resulted in higher in better patient
outcomes
it could there it's all and we're just
beginning just we're beginning of
regulations around always evolving these
days and we're just beginning to find
out all the potential use of the
precision medicines and quite possibly
on the spread to make the surface of how
it could affect clinical practice so
interesting I would like to once again
thank mr. Belson for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through September 21st 2018 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
me know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon
bye